how do you top one of the
highest-grossing most seen movies of all
time you give it a sequel that doesn't
do the exact same thing over but instead
continues the story and in a dark dark
way the Empire Strikes Back is often
said to be the best of the Star Wars
trilogy or really any of the Star Wars
films and yeah they're pretty much right
we open once again with the Empire
seeking out the rebels let again by
Darth Vader as Luke gets a message from
a deceased obi-wan that he is to seek
out Yoda the Jedi Master that taught him
after being attacked by the Empire Luke
separates from Han and Leia in order to
find this master Jedi and learn the ways
of the force while learning these new
ways the rest of the gang takes shelter
in Cloud City a place ruled by Lando
Calrissian but little does everybody
know that the Empire has an evil trap
for all of them especially for Luke who
Vader has a keen interest in it's so
refreshing that the sequel to one of the
highest-grossing films of all time is
actually doing something a little
different not just different but taking
chances the pacing is slower the imagery
is darker it wasn't telling the story
like it was a sequel it was telling it
like it was the second part in fact this
was the first time on the big screen
they actually put episode 5 on there
with Lucas revealing this is now a
six-part movie series why start at
number 4 who knows but people were
enjoying it so much they didn't care
they just figure he could do no wrong
which yeah now I get to that later
everybody likes this movie for different
reasons well actually that's not true
they all like for the same reason it's
darker there's more drama
liji on a cliffhanger it's taking this
happy-go-lucky adventure that we have
with the first one and making it much
more gritty me personally I like it
because it took the very basic good
versus evil story has started to gray it
out a little bit I think most people
know the big surprise in this film but
I'm not gonna give it away in case you
don't I will say when it was revealed I
didn't see a coming but my mind wasn't
quite blown like everyone else actually
I thought to myself yeah that sounds
about right
that solid line of good versus evil
black versus white was suddenly being
blurred and it was actually very
welcoming
much as we love to say the dark side and
the light side this suddenly made it a
little bit more interesting it didn't
always have to be the cowboy with the
black hand the cowboy with the white hat
you could get a little bit more
three-dimensional with it and speaking
of which the movie really does seem more
three-dimensional a lot of it is
spending time diving inward we have a
romance blooming with Han and Leia we
have Luke trying to figure out how to
use the force there's a lot more symbols
and foreshadowing in it in one a
direction I think a lot of kids didn't
see coming and he'll even probably a lot
of adults didn't see coming but that's
great because it just got us more
invested the effects once again for the
time are still pretty damn incredible
the puppet work on Yoda even though yeah
he does look like a muppet still feels
very much alive the eyes the expression
the moving of the wrinkles on his brow
it's the same as watching Kermit the
Frog you know he's not real but he feels
real he would later be replaced with a
CG Yoda and the prequels and even when
he looked the most realistic you never
got the impression he was really there
you got the impression obi-wan was
looking at nothing here you never feel
like Luke's just talking to a guy
holding a puppet you feel like he's
talking to Yoda and it's not just the
use of a great practical effect is the
use of great riding and acting all of it
plays a part I also love how much more
menacing they make the Empire in this
not that they were not threatening in
the original but good God
Vader just went from this guy who sort
of stood in the corner to this monstrous
beast whenever he comes out with that
lightsaber you feel the intimidation you
feel like you're gonna lose to this guy
this is when he suddenly went from just
being a cool bad guy to one of the
greatest villains ever he could lunge at
you and rip you apart but he could also
stand perfectly still and destroy you he
can be very patient and intelligent but
he can also be stubborn killing anyone
he just doesn't like it's a brilliant
depiction of someone you love to be
afraid of the movie also goes much more
into the philosophy of the force but
again not too much it talks about what
it is but not how it is it talks about
the experience but not why you're
experiencing it about feeling it but not
touching it and again it's not all done
in dialogue there's a great scene where
Luke just goes into this area in the
swamp and comes across Vader we know
it's not real
him it can't really be him and yet the
fight takes place and he sees his own
face inside the mask those are the exact
right choices that have you say oh my
god what does that mean what can it mean
it gives you just the right tools to
build your own conclusion again as good
storytelling should so yeah like
everyone else it's my favorite out of
the Star Wars films are still details
that don't make sense sure but it's the
same as the first one you overlook it
cuz the rest is just so good and you
know that's not the focus the focus is
to be sucked into this world and it's
characters at most the people who watch
it are it's more intense more
suspenseful poor visual more
philosophical more dramatic or when you
come to love the force is strong with
this one
you